the credits for the batman call him the
unseen arkham prisoner but real fans
know where they've seen him before
warning spoilers for the batman ahead
teasing a villain for the next movie at
the end of the current one is at this
point standard operating procedure for
comic book movies the most recent batman
movie the batman includes just such a
scene it's set in arkham asylum gotham
city's notoriously insecure institute
for the criminally insane the scene in
question features an exchange between
paul dano's riddler and a familiar
murderous clown played by rising star
barry kyogen most audience members will
tell you that the scene is a clear setup
for a batman sequel one that once again
sets the dark knight on a collision
course with the clown prince of crime
but there's more to this brief exchange
between two super criminals that might
immediately meet the eye director matt
reeves revealed in an interview
published in conjunction with the film's
release that he intended for the moment
to have a thematic significance within
the batman itself rather than
functioning as a glorified advertisement
for future films new friend of yours
i'm not so sure in a youtube interview
with ign director matt reeves provided
some insight into the barry kyogen joker
scene in the batman linking its function
within the film to some of the movie's
overarching themes reeves explained that
in his initial cut of the movie he
removed the arkham sequence between
wriggler and joker thinking it
unimportant to the movie's overall story
but when he did so the stakes within
another more crucial sequence a scene
later on between catwoman and batman
were diminished catwoman and batman care
about each other but at the end of the
day they're working on opposite sides of
the law they're also divided by their
attitudes towards gotham city while
batman clings to a desperate hope that
his crime-fighting efforts can somehow
make a difference in the grand scheme of
things catwoman is of the opinion that
the city will never change and that each
quelled threat will ultimately be
replaced by a new one remind you of
anything in the batman audiences already
understand the grim truth of catwoman's
words because they've just seen the
joker himself enter the picture how can
gotham ever change when that guy's on
the scene the joker scene then is a
potent illustration of the seemingly
limitless number of threats to the
public's health and well-being that the
numerous villains of gotham city will
always present this may be the riddler's
movie but the riddler is far from the
only villain in gotham he's just one of
them and now he has a new friend if this
continues it won't be long before you
nothing left matt reeves shared some
additional insight about barry kyogen
scene in the batman in an interview with
variety published the day after his
conversation with ign reeves explained
that originally there was another scene
with kyogen's unseen arkham prisoner
which saw batman go and visit the
detainee who greeted him like an old
friend the deleted scene which reeves
hopes to show viewers one day is said to
have a similar vibe to the scenes
between clarice starling and hannibal
lecter in the silence of the limbs hello
clarice
it's good to see you again
in addition to lending thematic weight
to catwoman's philosophical outlook on
gotham city reeves explained that
kyogen's joker was likewise featured in
order to accentuate the preponderance of
eccentric characters in gotham and
further develop the film's central
location the director said i thought
it'd be really neat if so much of the
fabric of gotham just already existed
and it was like an old warner brothers
gangster movie and if you took a certain
turn you might see a character in his
origins furthermore the implied threat
the joker poses to gotham city is meant
to reinforce the fact that batman's work
is forever ongoing reeves explained that
the scene's inclusion helped audiences
quote see that gotham was still gotham
and that batman really didn't have a
choice he has to keep doing what he's
gonna do according to reeves whether or
not kyogen reprises his role as the
joker in a future film has yet to be
determined but at the very least reeves
has made it clear that his scene in the
batman serves a clear purpose whether he
shows up again in a future movie or not
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
the batman are coming soon subscribe to
our youtube channel and hit the bell so
you don't miss a single one
[Music]